going a bit off topic I guess but did
you guys have uh birthday parties as
kids or did you go to other kids
birthday parties uh yeah uh yeah I did
but I mean I was born in July so I never
got to have like uh like the everyone
turns up it's yeah I got like two kids
oh yeah because everyone mine was always
on school holidays so I always had like
a birthday party yeah but like yeah it
was like it was you know it started off
at the McDonald's playpen the goat
the goat the ice cream cakes bro what's
your what's your reasoning fast no
because like I would always notice that
the people like the kids that ended up
like growing up to high school that had
like a big social group were the kids
that you know had like the biggest and
most kids come to their birthday parties
you know that's I don't know if that's
correlation I don't know if that's just
that's so anecdotal that's completely
anecdotal that you are completely right
this is this is [__] database from
my one personal experience I I was just
like huh because because part of the
reason I like I've grown up really not
hating my birthday but just being really
indifferent about like my birthday and
having birthday parties part of the
reason for that was because uh I'm like
a late May baby so when my birthday came
around it was like exam season everyone
had to study so I wouldn't even try to
like have any birthday parties I think I
had like one as a kid
um and then it was birthday trauma yeah
it's like birthday trauma I'm like if I
don't invite anyone then I don't have to
be disappointed if no one comes to my
birthday because I know everyone's got
exams right so I've grown up being like
completely indifferent about it
um and it's been interesting you know
meeting Sydney who's like the complete
opposite of just like I love my birthday
I I always want to like this is like the
time I get to hang out with my friends
and make it like some feel special is
she the person that calls it a birthday
month no she doesn't go that far she
doesn't go that far but uh she does
always look for something to make a
birthday feel special and she tries to
give that to other people as well and
like haven't seen like seen that seeing
that like seeing seeing the other side
of things I'm just like damn that's a
that's such a small thing that I never
got in my life like having having like a
small thing of like having the birthday
feel special or doing something that
goes out your way to make that person
feel special but I'm like damn now that
I've seen now that I see her do it uh
for other people and see how she reacts
when she uh when you know I go out my
way to do something for her for her
birthday like small things actually
matter you know a small thing small
things matter they build up yeah they
they build up and uh especially when it
comes to friendships going out your way
to make them know that you're a friend
or make them feel special that's uh
that's something that uh
some something that I've never really
thought about when I was growing up I
was like friends of friends you know
friends of friend but just making just
making your Bros feel special or making
and inviting people to hang out is a
very core part of friendship you know
yeah I can't always be that you know a
word of advice would be uh don't be that
guy who just waits for invitations
always you should always try and make
stuff yep you know not even if you're
like I don't know what to do she's like
you like hanging out with them right
yeah just hang out just just invite them
out yeah you know
inviting people is one of the most
important parts of making someone feel
like they're you know a friend yeah yeah
they're like oh they considered me oh
they thought about me when they wanted
to spend time with people you know
that's that's like a really important
thing of course it's very easy to like
Smile as a teenager I was like now
people just invite me to things yeah I
was the same way I was like that passive
guy yeah it was just like yeah I'll just
get invited to things you know I'll play
video games I don't I don't need I'm not
gonna do anything like but if someone
wants to invite me out I'll come you
know what I mean so yeah yeah but then
it's like you know people appreciate you
showing up as well that's very important
too but yeah you know showing people
that it's appreciated and that you you
value that time and you would like them
present that things is important uh and
that's something that I think you know
there's [__] that never taught you no no
none of this stuff's ever talked to you
and you just have to learn it because
you're just like all right well I guess
this is what being a nice friend means
yeah but also I don't know I felt like I
learned a lot of weird things being from
a small town and you learn small town
etiquette and not not it's like no no
it's just weird because I feel that like
what do you mean just like I don't know
like stuff that was considered very
normal where you're from might not be
normal where you are right now and how
you have to kind of adapt to that and
kind of be like oh okay just because
there was a gathering every week at
maybe the pub
now I don't have that how do I make sure
that like how do I make friends when
there's no Palms like if there was a
place where everyone would just be at
yeah because there was nowhere else to
go you could reliably meet people there
it's like oh now I have to like okay I
can't just wander into a place and meet
everyone who knows everyone yeah you
know what I mean like yeah and maybe
even just growing up with
when when everyone's from a small town
um and even like the kids right because
you know when you're a kid you get a lot
of your how you think about things from
your parents yeah all the kids
I mean included you'd get like a lot of
the stuff fed to you from your your
parents and I feel like the internet is
like throwing a massive spanner into
that
um and I just remember thinking like the
whole time when I was a kid uh I was
like man I just I just don't feel like I
think the same way like everyone speaks
around me and I I think that's why I
felt like really like outcasted for a
while because I just I was like man I
want to do all this weird [__] on that I
saw on the internet and everyone's like
oh let's just yeah I like the like the
football that my dad told me to watch
meanwhile Conor's there like have you
seen poo poo peepee meanwhile she's
hilarious yeah I'm like I'm like
shouting at Americans on COD and I'm
looking at all this stuff online about
Japan when I'm like 12. this is so cool
what are we all doing yeah
um but then again I feel like that's a
very weird mindset of like I think I'm
Different to everyone and it's like
maybe I'm not different maybe I'm just a
problem I don't know yeah I mean I I got
that feeling whenever I go to you know
meet uh go to Sydney's Hometown because
yeah that is that is a very use like
home that is a very small town and it
almost kind of feels like oh she's gonna
hear me for saying this it almost um it
almost felt like incestuous in a way
just because every I swear to God
everyone's known each other and they've
known each other like from birth yeah
right and then it's like that yeah and
like like everyone everyone who's a like
a everyone who's friends there
are like childhood friends and that's
that's good I think that's great because
you you are also you know that's what's
the situation there's a lot of friendly
people who you're often introduced to
throughout your life if you've often
taught a lot of social skills uh that I
think are really important whereas I
think sometimes in you know in people
who are raised exclusively in cities
it's a lot more things you should be
careful about yeah you can't just
randomly go meet the people you can't
can't just be left in the middle of a
shopping uh I don't know Supermarket
yeah and then your parents will come
pick you up later or some [__] I don't
[__] know why you do that but yeah
you you we got up to a lot of weird [__]
yeah I would not do now for sure because
because I think the one the one Trope I
guess the one Trope I'm missing in my
life is I've never had a childhood
friend you know what is that I don't
know what that feels like whenever I see
that in anime I see like oh I I have a
childhood friend and uh there's no
friends from your childhood who you have
contact even like no you could hit no
like zero yeah
Define childhood like you've known them
since you're a child yeah like since
there's like no one you could hit up and
be like hey how you doing man
um everyone that I've known when I was
like a child like like pretty young uh
I'd say like the only friend I've really
kept in contact with the furthest we go
back is probably like end of high school
when we're like going to University
that's that's like no one from like
Primary School no not a single person I
can probably hit up like
half a mile score which not a lot of
people by the way yeah
half of my year and I feel like yeah we
could get a drink it'd be fun yeah uh
and then there's like three that I would
be able to hit up and be like hey man
come to Japan come hang out and they'd
be like oh yeah it'll work then maybe
yeah sure I don't have that I don't know
what that feels like maybe I don't know
maybe it's just like a city thing but
you have childhood friends right a
majority of my friends are childhood
friends yeah seriously yeah so like my
mom did this like five head move uh when
I when I was born because like you know
Sydney is uh is is a big city right and
uh lots of suburbs lots of different
like Community uh communities of
different ethnicities all over the city
um and you know my mom coming from Japan
obviously all of her friends that were
back in Japan right
um so she found when I was born she
found this like Mother's group that just
consisted of Japanese moms with like
non-japanese husbands so basically
they're like halfu kids
yeah and they and and my Mama went oh
this is perfect because a I can make
Japanese friends who live in Sydney as
well and they all have hafu kids that my
kids could be friends with as well so my
mum would basically take me my sister to
these like these these Japanese mum
Gatherings and I would meet all of these
[__] half Japanese kids who were like
pretty much the same age as me maybe
give or take a couple of years and yeah
it's like you know some of those people
are like still my best friends that have
known them for over [__] 25 years now
yeah and it's [__] wild like yeah
when I went back to when we went to
Australia last month for the convention
and I went back to Sydney I caught up
with some of them and it was really
weird we were just like reminiscing
being like isn't it weird that I've
known you for like over 25 [__] years
of my life and like that's that's wild
to think to me to me that's a long time
to me that's like family at that point
it is yeah they all like family for sure
yeah and it's it's great oh God
I wish that was me so I I I'm aware that
I I am very blessed in that situation
yeah um and if it wasn't for my mom who
again was the was the genius that's why
she's the goat I basically like paid to
win
my mom was like I got you bro yeah I got
you here I'm gonna whale on your account
here guys he's all your friends
yeah I don't know I think also you
probably had a pretty normal upbringing
which probably helped a lot too I think
a lot of Define normal wow
by normal I mean like uh like no
troubles yeah like financially stable
yeah uh I guess your parents are still
together yeah you know I think that's
like that's like a big thing and then
like just yeah I mean I'm like Financial
Security is a huge thing as a child as a
kid that I [__] certainly didn't
appreciate when I was growing up oh yeah
I was just like yeah my mom and dad
always together and uh we never have to
worry about money I think I don't know I
get an Xbox so I sounded pretty good
right yeah I don't know like I think
that's that's a huge factor in when
you're growing up right how sure it is I
think definitely small town it's a lot
easier to kind of have that stability
yeah yeah there's not a lot of weird
stuff happening yeah at least when I was
growing up would you would you guys go
back to your high school reunions
sure why not I miss my high school
reunion late my 10-year reunion oh yeah
it happened recently but obviously I was
here so I missed out I kind of wish I
went to it really realistically I'm I'm
like no but then the ego part of my head
is like [__] yeah
you know what I mean just rock up with
two security guards
sorry boys sorry take sunglasses off
yeah I mean you know of course okay of
course to deny my ego would be the
biggest lie ever
um uh but you know I also think that
when I sometimes I'm just fundamentally
I'm just a very different person from
who I was yeah in high school and I
think
you know when I sometimes speak to some
people who I feel haven't changed at all
since high school I'm like is that good
I don't know if that's good or that's
impressive like I'm not like well it
depends it depends how they were in high
school right yeah yeah I mean there's
some people who definitely I haven't
changed them they certainly should have
changed uh yeah you know
yeah I'm sure we all know that yeah of
course we all have that friend or person
we've seen who is literally identical to
how they've been living their life the
exact same way yeah yeah and you're just
like God I hate you so much and I'm so
glad you haven't changed because your
life is [__] you're a dick to
everyone yeah yeah
um
but you know there's I think
it's it's an important thing to change
and to grow and to learn maybe certain
behaviors maybe you do that you could
improve upon and I think that's
something that I uh I think also as a
YouTuber you're like forced to because
everyone is well they don't have to you
can be a [__] uh but a lot of people
are always very judgmental of you us
especially on a [__] two-hour podcast
things we say or yeah like Lord knows
that we're we're we get we get some heat
but then it's also like a really good
thing to in in one part of my head I'm
like yeah that's great I can actually I
have like a [__] dedicated list of
people judging everything I say and and
telling me how to improve and giving me
some help because sometimes I I maybe
just thinks things towards uh certain
topics or maybe my behavior towards
certain things is just not as good as
I'd like it to be or I could improve it
in a way that where I don't know I just
I feel better about myself or maybe it's
more healthy long term it's kind of it's
kind of like a good moral not like a
good moral check so every now and I
guess you know I I think I speak for all
of us that we do we never try to do
anything bad but sometimes sometimes
sometimes like you know you're just
living your life and maybe
you're just doing things and you're like
oh this thing I did could have been
damaging to yeah in this kind of way to
either myself maybe people around me
because I just didn't realize and you'd
never have that kind of feedback loop to
to have that maybe some people point out
like hey maybe that thing you said
wasn't very good yeah okay and then
you're like I'm gonna go look because
yeah friends sometimes don't tell you
hey man that wasn't cool yeah because
that just sometimes doesn't happen and
that's where real friends come in real
friends and call you out on your
[__] yeah like mate you were kind of
a [__] dick and
not gonna lie you need people like that
man yeah yeah which is what okay one of
the big things as well is uh conflict
right I feel like you know
um some people will go out of their way
to avoid you know writing so conflict is
always an unpleasant uh an unpleasant
topic and yeah just an unpleasant
experience but I feel if you've gone
through a friendship and you've not had
like either done a little bit of like
conflict resolution you know even if
it's just a [__] stupid drunken
argument like or something like that
it's it's it's like if you're tiptoeing
around you know if you're tiptoeing
around hurting your friends feelings
then you will never know where the
boundaries will lie right you know what
I mean yeah I think conversation is a
very important part of a long lasting
friendship and if your friend does
something [__] up it's important that
you tell them they [__] up right away
yeah because then you know I think most
people uh if I told you hey gone that
boneless chicken thing you said was not
cool
maybe you reacted kind of sour to that
you're like what the [__] what the
[__] wrong with you I didn't do
anything wrong I'd be like oh okay well
either I'm wrong or which has never
happened yeah um or you know maybe this
is someone who I shouldn't pay much mind
to and then maybe they're like not a
good friend yeah but I think that's a
great way of just learning because I
think ultimately if someone is a really
great friend they will appreciate that
you came to them and told them hey yeah
I think YouTube wasn't cool yeah you
know because you know you you if you get
confronted about something you should
take that as oh I've clearly upset this
person why wouldn't I want to make this
better why wouldn't I want to improve
the situation why would I be getting
defensive over a situation when I you
know this person clearly feels offended
for something and if there's someone I
value there's got to be something there
that I need to address or unpack yeah
even if you end up you didn't do
anything wrong I think it's important to
at least hear them out and and just have
a conversation yeah walk through it yeah
I think that's a very important part of
being definitely an adult and also
knowing when to pick confrontation I
think sometimes you can get you can get
a little too kung-ho with it and you can
put two in yeah if you get too pedantic
with it then that's just a quick
fireworks I think that's the sound that
comes with experience an age you just
you just kind of learn you're like this
is really not a big deal yeah if I make
it a big deal I'm gonna cause more
problems in the long run yeah
um because you know I'm sure we've had
that one friend who's maybe brought
something up where you're like what the
[__] like what it's like why is this
even a problem why are we talking about
this yeah yeah you're like what is this
an issue like you know we've all had
that and you're like you know and even
then it's like it's important to work
through that and yeah let's break it
down like what what's right what's going
on here most of the time it's it's not
the actual problem most of the time it's
something else it's something else
that's uh that's a deeper problem it's
using that as a Crux to like kick off
the conversation yeah yeah yeah you're
like there is this problem by the way
here's the real issue yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's talk about let's let's unpack
that
are you good man are you good normally
most of the time when that happens there
is something not good that they might
not like be aware of that yeah like okay
that's that's the right now we know the
root of the problem that's okay I get it
now I get it uh yeah some people just
need to talk about their feelings and
[__] some people just need to vent and
uh yeah okay so I I had that like I'm
that kind of like I had this like awful
I don't know if it's an awful
personality trait but it is like the way
just my mind works whenever
sometimes someone would come to me with
a problem my gut reaction would be like
let's fix it and then it took me like
age to realize some people just need to
vent about their day yeah they're not
looking for a solution
just want to hear have someone listen
they don't yeah they don't want answers
they don't want you to suggest how to
improve it they're just like they're
just like please
yeah and then end of conversation
because me me my engineering blind would
be like all right I've heard the problem
let's not break it down and this is how
you fix this is a step-by-step yeah if
you reply to every time someone's like
this problem well I would have done this
yeah you should do this yes I I
literally used to do that and I hated
that I used to do that yeah everyone
does it at one point because they're
like they they feel like they're helping
the situation yeah yeah a lot of the
time people just want you to listen and
engage with it so just ask more
questions not not in a way of like how
can I fix this but like hey yeah well
why did this person do this wait why
does why does that bother you why do you
feel about this yeah just just making
people know that you're listening and
hearing them and understanding them is
just so important yeah for sure